[Music]
[Music]
dad's placed just greater emphasis on
the public health aspects of the crisis
while Republicans tended to talk about
more generalized national unity
Republicans replacing a greater emphasis
on China and also sort of mobilizing the
country into combat in terms you're in a
fight coronavirus and mean coronavirus
so word coronavirus is
disproportionately used by republicans
[Music]
we started the timeline for this data at
the first explicit mention of
coronavirus which is January 17th and
then we let it run up until the end of
March we have this dictionary that we
use to flag terms even down to the
hashtags that the parties send it to use
we specified a machine learning
algorithm to look at the relationship
between two different term usage and
partisanship among a certain set of
tweets the sort of 3/4 ish level of
accuracy that we got is similar to
what's been observed elsewhere in floor
speeches we take that level of
out-of-sample classification accuracy
and that ability to correctly identify
the partisanship of who said what even
people who are well aware of what the
scientific consensus is on an issue may
reject that consensus if it becomes an
issue that implicates their cultural
identity citizens were being asked to be
an active participant in the public
response so it's particularly important
that things like wearing a mask or not
going to bars don't become cultural
signifiers that implicate your your
political identities
we have planned analysis to look at
similar patterns of Governors who we
think might be less polarized we don't
have Trump sweets and their term sweets
are obviously important what is
happening at the presidential election
level with Trump and bi there are a lot
of sort of people thinking about this
now so I'm sure we'll start to see
really really interesting stuff coming
out soon
[Music]